the Joe Rogan experience that ya loves
most people would think that I'm
conservative that I'm a Republican or an
all-right or something like that
I vote left on almost everything except
gun control I just don't think the
people understand what they're talking
about when they're talking about gun
control I don't think they understand
the nuances of the Second Amendment or
the nuances of taking away people's
ability to defend themselves or to hunt
or to you know to own something that may
or may not be used against someone else
but they never would use it it's you
don't have the right to tell people what
they can and can't have just because
some people abuse things it's like this
is a very complex conversation that
people on the Left want to boil down to
guns are equal bad oh for sure it's like
it's like I don't have them and I can
understand why someone would yes but
therefore I don't know why you would but
at the same time they're you know and
we're sitting here with a drink but the
same time you look at like alcohol and
one could make a very cogent argument
about the overall destructiveness of
abused alcohol for sure
but people I don't hear a lot of people
talking about prohibition no no I had
this great Crenshaw I don't drink and
drive Dan Crenshaw is a congressman is
not for legalized marijuana you know but
he likes scotch so we had this weird
conversation we come on man stop and I'm
like when we're standing in front of a
ashtray filled with blunts and they said
this idea that like if you're a
marijuana smoker that's somehow another
you lazy like workout with me come get
up with me to stop